I'm Kaye mckin and this is a special
edition of the Ingram angle from New
York City tonight judges divided a
Florida judge handing Trump a win
pausing litigation in his classified
documents case but on the other hand a
New York judge ruling moments ago not to
halt his civil fraud trial we have all
the details tonight with GW Professor
Jonathan Turley he'll be here to weigh
in but first 4 years the liberal media
made a cottage industry of vilifying
conservatives remember how according to
them president Trump and his supporters
They Were Somehow responsible for
racism that's the extremist thinking
that Donald Trump represents and the
hate mongering that unfortunately he
poisoning the Republican Party he is a
representative of their intolerance dare
I say it racism he's a representative of
their misogyny he's a representative of
the intolerance president Trump knows
what he's doing when he's stoking racism
Trump and trumpism and all that it
represents that Nexus of racism and
sexism and greed it's always the same
Playbook no matter who it is it's racism
but now that Trump's out of office guess
what he in half of America still the
problem Donald Trump and the mager
Republicans represent an extremism that
threatens the very foundations of our
Republic M Republicans are determined to
spread anger hate and Division
this magga threat is a threat to the
brick and mortar of our Democratic
institutions the blood red background
that was fitting the unifier and chief
as he calls himself ratcheting up the
hateful rhetoric taking us down a
dangerous New Road in the media they
took his cue we call it here triple
trickle down hatred that's what it is
commander-in-chief gives the
instructions to the media and now here
we are no longer content with the usual
smears of racism and bigotry now Trump
and his supporters many of you watching
are an exential threat to America's very
survival he's the villain he's easy
what's difficult is that so many of our
fellow Americans buy into this it is
abundantly clear that the Republican
party is now unafraid to stand with
those who would turn to violence if you
don't stop it now it will only get worse
and only jail will get to him Direct
directly H the message is clear Trump
belongs in prison and if you support him
in the America First agenda they may
Target you too this is why we've seen
the doj remember that letter targeting
parents as domestic terrorists all
because they don't want porn in their
kindergarten classrooms and peaceful
protesters outraged over the left's
radical abortion demands they targeted
pro-lifers they went to Mark Hal's house
with guns the FBI but thankfully he was
acquitted by a jury we still have juries
in this country and it's why as Newsweek
reported this week the FBI is targeting
Trump supporters now the FBI disputes
that but one senior intelligence
official stated Trump's Army constitutes
the greatest threat of violence
domestically the left is not hiding
their authoritarian impulses anymore and
there's no better example of that than
the Oho likable Hillary Clinton not
content with just labeling half the
country as deplorables she now is
proposing something you would expect to
hear from Kim
Jong-un many of those extremists those
Mega extremists um take their marching
orders from Donald Trump at some point
you know maybe there needs to be a
formal deprogramming of the cult members
but something needs to happen a formal
deprogramming you heard that correctly
that's what she said from first lady to
Secretary of State to presidential
candidate to the founder of America's
first reeducation Camp that's what she's
asking for she said it there's no
misconstruing that hopefully she and the
left will fail in that endeavor as much
as the previous ones for the sake of the
entire country hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else